les 24 hooligans qui comparaît sont pour
la plupart originaire de liverpool
liverpool où ils sont pour certains
d'entre eux déjà rentrer ce soir en
attendant d'être convoqué à tour de rôle
liverpool ou le drame du heysel a été
douloureusement ressentie personne
n'arrivant s expliquer comment ces
jeunes supporters de foot ont pu se
transformer en roulis gad à mon anglais
d'origine russe signifiant délinquants
vandal anne robert herbin teboul ont
mené l enquête sur place à liverpool
trois ans après rien n'est plus comme
avant ces décors vides
c'est tout ce qui reste des dogues de
liverpool dans les années 60 50 mille
docker travail est ici aujourd'hui moins
de 2000 hangar désert grue brouillés
depuis la crise industrielle liverpool
la florissante vite au ralenti les
habitants le disent eux mêmes avec une
certaine amertume
heureusement il nous reste les beatles
ils ont commencé dans cette rue et le
football qui est partout moi j'ai grandi
dans cette ville
ici tout le monde et supporters les
femmes les hommes et même les enfants et
quand les reds jouent les raids et joue
pour nous tous
et quand les reds gagnent ils gagnent
pour nous tous mais ici depuis le zèle
la grande famille du foot à ses brebis
galeuses comme marc 23 ans il y a trois
ans il était tôt et zèle
aujourd'hui il est inculpé d'homicide ap
moscou
je vais voir des matchs depuis l'âge de
6 ans avec mes parents et tout seul
depuis l'âge de 10 ans mais jamais eu
d'ennuis avant alors une jeune fille
passau légales sont en ont une
pourtant aujourd'hui marquée sur le banc
des accusés le zèle à liverpool
c'est un peu la fin d'une époque le
match du samedi maintenant c'est ça des
supporters surveiller en permanence
comme ici à la gare de manchester au
départ dissimuler ces caméras sont
maintenant bien en évidence la police
ayant constaté qu'elles ont un effet
dissuasif
les images enregistrées peuvent en effet
servir en cas de procès les supporters
le savent ils ont changé tactique
maintenant les supporters ne peut plus
aucune marque distinctive t-shirt ou
écharpe de leur club il s'habille comme
les voyageurs ordinaires dans le train
même quadrillage policier en civil et en
tenue
interdiction formelle de se lever
pendant le trajet porte de communication
entre vagues ont fermé à clé pour les
matches à haut risque trains spéciaux
pour éviter les contacts avec d'autres
voyageurs
et puis à l'arrivée en gare de liverpool
cette image surréaliste une longue
cohorte forme qui fera à pied les quatre
kilomètres séparant la gare du stade
autour du stade c'est la gare de monthey
qui prend le relais un dispositif mis en
place depuis le slc tant l'ambiance
militaire à l'ambiance par sportif
résultat un paradoxe
peu d'incidents à l'intérieur du stade
d'ailleurs les supporters locaux sortent
les premiers les autres doivent attendre
une heure avant d'évacuer la tribune
mais c'est à l'extérieur que la violence
reprend d'où le constat amer de ce
sociologue
ces mesures sont totalement insuffisants
madame thatcher a eu raison de se mettre
en colère après le sl mais plus de
sanctions plus de contrôles à
l'interdiction de l'alcool toutes ces
mesures traite les symptômes et non les
causes tant que le malaise social ne
sera pas pris en compte le hooliganisme
continuera bref à ton déplacer le
problème de la violence au lieu de le
régler peut-être ici même à liverpool il
ya un mois dix blessés à la sortie d'un
concert de michael jackson les
hooliganisme où l'honneur perdu de
liverpool